inside the secret of surface labs of
Microsoft you see one thing the original
design was a big change from Microsoft
business as usual this is not something
where it was in our DNA 20 years ago
it's not in our DNA
ten years ago Hardware design with
constant iterative improvements over
many years this is not one of these
things where we just started nine months
ago and we came up with a great idea the
design tools are a sight to behold like
a magnesium slicing CNC machine you're
starting to see it you're starting to
see that same bill it back there come to
life right here and this is our model
shop the model shop employs all sorts of
tools old school and new tooling
machines table saws power drills 3d
printers and all sorts of materials to
model with acrylics plastics metal it's
a modern Geppetto's workshop of
industrial design Microsoft's first
tablets surfaced in October 2012 and it
flopped it led to a 900 million dollar
write down but with each release the
product has gotten better and market
share still low is quietly growing this
is the hinge for the Microsoft Surface
kickstand at 400% the actual size they
had it milled here at the machine shop
in Redmond Washington so they get a real
sense of what it would look like what it
would feel like what it would sound like
so when they made the actual kickstand
at a much smaller size they knew what
they're getting into to make the third
time a charm surface 3 has got to get
everything right you iterate iterate
iterate iterate and you get skinny
skinny skinny thinner and lighter
thinner and lighter thinner and lighter
grams tens of grams are huge currency
for us and thousands of man-hours went
into designing this stylus we wanted to
take this of analog icon tool
fundamental tool and turn it into
digital all those iterations all that
inventing has given Microsoft what they
think is a productivity tool to replace
the laptop until you get to that perfect
piece where you go this is it
you